so I was watching one of my favorite TV
shows Dragon's Den and a story came on
about an 82 year old entrepreneur who
Arlene Dickinson ended up investing with
and the story moved me to tears and help
remind me again that being an
entrepreneur isn't just about making
money it's about making your dreams come
true I hope you enjoy the clip just like
I did we would like to demonstrate a
bold new concept into what to make a
sawhorse should be the bracket adjusts
to raise and extend a workbench on any
uneven surface a feature Sam designed in
his garage more than 30 years ago Sam
how old are you 82 82 oh my gosh despite
decades of setbacks that kept his
invention off store shelves Arlene saw
something she could build on that feels
like the bracket is hugely innovative
for a whole bunch of reasons ultimately
I would like to walk into a store and
see it being sold Arlene bought a
hundred percent of Sam's business for
seventy five thousand dollars and a five
percent royalty we'll see what happens
with this but at the worst case there's
an end to a story there right
I'm here in Vancouver it's been over two
years since I made the deal in the
Denver 3ds offers this is the most
amount of work I've ever done on any
deal in the den I have such a big
surprise for Sam I can't wait to see the
look on his face we have gone through
everything from happy to re-design
redevelop reengineer get it manufactured
it's being a ton of work but worth every
single minute 30 years ago Sam had a
dream and it started in his garage and
today Sam's dream is about to become a
reality
hi Sam yes I'm Jeff kinnaird vice
president merchandising for the home
depot canada welcome I've got something
I want to show you
this is a surprise
now wait to see the look on space
dad
the Knicks no cash
Oh
that is
hey if it does
dangerous thank you sir
Oh
I'm so glad that we were able to do this
I took a long time a freezer prized yeah
good it's all over that the the good
news salmon is not just gonna be here
it's gonna be in 180 home depot stores
across the country great so toughening
everywhere for you right yeah yeah yeah
I just love to watch him over there
just a watching this awesome this is
this is it soak it in that's wonderful
it just makes me feel soul proud and
happy and you know to see not to sams
dream come true but his family so
excited it was just plot
36 years ago to this is it's been a
journey ultimately that is worthwhile
now
you